hello everybody welcome back to the
journey with jess and i'm getting red
pill going from blue pill to red pill
and don't forget to subscribe
like the video comment any other videos
or anything you want to comment down
below today we're going to be reacting
to
thomas
so
we should see how it goes today
so guys this was the most requested out
of all of the
oh i'm excited okay
i'm always nervous whenever i start a
video
like i don't know what to expect okay so
i'm gonna give you a little background
thomas sowell is an economist okay so
that's that's his background and he he
writes books okay
thomas sowell if you see this i would
love to interview you please come on
thomas but he doesn't do interviews
often so this interview has five million
views
yeah yeah
okay okay let's here we go
it happens to me all the time and it
happened just this week
a young person i'd never met introduced
himself to me and said that when he saw
our guest today
on an earlier episode of this program he
felt he was seeing a man who knew how to
think
dr thomas sowell on uncommon knowledge
now
[Music]
welcome to uncommon knowledge i'm peter
robinson
thomas sol has studied and taught
economics intellectual history and
social policy at institutions that
include cornell brandeis ucla and
amherst now a senior fellow at the
hoover institution dr sol has published
more than a dozen books including the
classic a conflict of visions
coming soon a revised edition of his
most recent volume discrimination and
disparities
tom soul welcome thank you
you
so
before
he is into it um it's like for me it's
cool to see
like just black people in like spaces
like that and just to hear like the
accolades i feel like they're they're
out there but
we just don't hear about him and i was
like wondering like i wonder why we
don't but that's how i wanted to say
yeah i think part of his problem is he
hates the media so he really he really
doesn't do interviews often
and he's still so well known in in this
space of youtube yeah
if you know you know
grew up in harlem dropped out of high
school to join the marine corps during
the korean war
received an undergraduate degree from
harvard
a masters from columbia
and your doctorate from the university
of chicago
all of which pales by comparison with
the fact that you once tried out for the
brooklyn dodgers
but
during this period from harlem
to the university of chicago
throughout your 20s you've said you
spent most of the decade of your
twenties as a marxist yes
oh wait do you know what a marxist is no
i was like uh who wait i wanna i wanna
google it to make sure i get the
definition right but i think that just
means more left
guys this is my new merch on the screen
if you want to buy the merch
marks
okay marxism is a method of
socioeconomic analysis that uses
materialistic interpretation of
historical
oh god
i i want to say just more liberal we'll
just go with that yeah because i still
was like
sorry let us know in the comments break
it down and break it down they'd be
using big words
i still don't understand and then i have
to google the big words that they use in
definition i'm just like huh i i think
it's just more left like leaning more
like okay
why what was it what
what was the attraction
well i guess i first
was uh
very puzzled see you there there's one
little question i would make
uh at age 16 i was a dropout
high school dropout
uh and i went to work full-time
as a western union messenger
uh
and uh delivering telegrams did lorraine
tell you we better say that because
there will be a generation that won't
know what western union was because yeah
that's true too right uh and so i i work
i worked in the area area of manhattan
called the chelsea district which is
around 23rd street
ninth avenue
and at the end of the day i had uh
several ways of getting back home like
the easiest
fastest way was with a subway which was
a nickel in those days
when i was feeling flush i might go for
a bus
for a dime
and then when i was really getting
reckless i would take the fifth avenue
bus which was the elite of the buses
was 15 cents and so i would walk over to
fifth avenue take that bus
and it would take me up uh through all
the
glamorous parts of fifth avenue past the
empire state building uh past the great
uh stores and things of that sort
uh and then on 57th street it would turn
and and it was this is just the elite
part of town sure right park starts yes
and then and you
know this park starts at 59th oh sorry
57th i would turn over it again the same
kind of scene past carnegie hall right
up columbus circle there was no trump
tower at that time and uh on up to about
72nd street and go out to fifth ave out
to the riverside drive which is another
elite area so for miles after that you
have all these wonderful luxury
apartment buildings and so on
and finally around 120
30th street
uh it would go on a long viaduct
and then he would do a right turn back
into the occupied area and there you'd
see the tenements
and i would wonder why is this
i mean why why why this huge disparity
and there was nobody else there was no
other other explanation around
there there was nothing there was
nothing there other than marxism
uh i know i stumbled across i had not
read marks but i i i bought a
second-hand pair a set of encyclopedias
small set
for some ridiculously low price
and there
where you grew up did you ever
see that whereas like one
one road can have all these nice big
houses but then on the next block it's
just like completely different
i grew up on 40 acres
okay so we didn't really have like
neighborhoods
i grew up on a bunch of land was that
how it was where you grew up
kind of i grew up i grew up in like a
a township so it was a small town and it
had like farms on the outskirts but as
soon as you got out of
the town and into the next city so the
next city for me
um it was holly and then fenton was the
next city it was nice and then it was
like davisburg and waterford
were the next cities over and those were
like nice areas they always called holly
like the rednecks opponent town because
we had a lot of farms and stuff in it
and so i i saw that a little bit growing
up i didn't see it a lot more until i
got to california where i'm at in
california
it's
like low income area but literally if
you drive up the street it's
nice houses nice area and it's such a
a big difference but like within
seconds or minutes between each other
and
i've always wondered like why
is that and i just was wondering if you
had experienced that um actually when
you were talking i remembered it was
like that in milwaukee how do i think
about it like milwaukee
um they had a town called short shortage
i think it was or sure
shorewood shorewood that's it
yeah no no sure one
and i was in downtown milwaukee and like
where i lived it was like
not a safe area like my car got broken
into a couple times yeah yeah partially
because i forgot to lock it
so it didn't really get broken into it
i don't really have anything in it but
they took my charger i was salty okay
i could not charge my car the next
and like a couple coins but i was like
whatever but uh at least i didn't take
the whole car exactly saying how hard
that was i'm not i'm not wired no no so
um then
but like i moved that summer into uh
like with my church oh okay and that the
people i lived with it was like the
nicest area thank god so so it's
interesting but that was within a couple
miles honestly like complete opposite
ads it's it's crazy and if you get
deeper into like la it's even
broader and it's
it's just
interesting yeah
i looked up karl marx i'd heard the name
and the stuff that he said
seemed to make sense
and then later on i would get more and
more into it
uh and uh
uh the
argument was that the the rich had
gotten rich by taking from the poor
right
and well that that was that was one
explanation but it was interesting there
was no other explanation out there
really and that's true largely in our
college's universities today but so so
by the time you went to harvard
undergrad well so
you drop out at the age of 16
and you start reading marks in your late
teens i know i start reading walks
yes 1949
at age 19. age 19
and then you're in the marine corps for
a couple of years what what was it two
three years oh two years it was actually
one
one year 11 months and five days but
who's counting
all right so by the time you went to
harvard
you had already become intellectually
engaged with marxism yes and remained
and harvard didn't talk you out of it
and
the study of economics at harvard didn't
talk you out of it nor did getting a
masters at columbia nor did getting a
doctorate
at chicago
dissuade you from marxism is that and
you studied with milton friedman of all
people how could you have sat in milton
friedman's classroom and remained a
marxist something i'm going to give you
a little bit of a background so um when
he's saying like how could you be a
marxist he's saying like more liberal
economic policies i think guys i could
be wrong
so like basically more like like free
stuff from the government where
conservatives are more like
individualistic policies okay which
they're going to get more into so um the
economist they're talking about is a
very conservative economist so he's
saying how could you have like studied
with him and still come out left okay
and the
guy that he was studying with is more
individual
yeah individualistic policies so less
like government handouts
does that make sense yes yes yes it is
people are just stubborn
but uh what really changed me uh
was not the university of chicago uh it
was
my first job working in a professional
capacity uh government i was a summer
intern this is after chicago or no no
while i was still a graduate student got
it uh
and so during the summer vacation i
worked in the u.s department of labor
and i
began to realize from a number of things
that
the government is not simply the
personification of the general will like
rousseau or others the government is an
institute the government institutions
have their own institutional uh
interests uh one involving minimum wage
law i was a big supporter of that
but i also knew that there was an
argument that minimum wage laws simply
price low wage workers out of a job
and uh my my first assignment was was
dealt with minimum wages in puerto rico
and as i looked at the numbers i would
see is they would jack up the minimum
wage this is a number number of jobs
would go down and so forth
but there were two explanations one was
that of the economist that you priced
the people out of out of a job
and the other was that there are there
were
hurricanes that come through puerto rico
you see
during the
sugar harvesting and therefore i was
studying the sugar industry and
therefore it destroyed a lot of the crop
therefore you wouldn't hire as many
workers now in chicago had been taught
that if there are two different theories
there should be somewhat some empirical
evidence in principle that could
distinguish what would happen under one
theory from what would happen under the
other right and so i wrestled with that
for the most of the summer and one
morning i came in and i said i got it
what we need are data on the amount of
sugar clean standing in the fields
before the hurricane struck
and as i waited for the congratulations
i could see stricken looks around me in
the room like this guy has stumbled on
something they will ruin us all
you know
and they say well we don't have those
data i said oh i'll bet the department
of agriculture has it he said well well
but we that doesn't mean we haven't uh
you
do you think that people like he was
saying have
certain data to
to essentially make things better but
it wouldn't benefit them so they don't
bring it out
do you see it you can't unsee it
once you see it you can't i always
thought that but i didn't want it to be
true
well it's because like
like the minimum wage law it's so it's
so easy
like that you can be
i think you don't even need to be an
economist to understand that if you jack
the price off of something people less
people are gonna do it yeah so a lot of
you know who hurts a lot from minimum
wage laws teenagers really yeah because
if you say um
we're only hiring people like let's say
they jacked it up to 30 an hour who are
the first people that are going to go
the least skills yeah teenagers
okay and low skilled people that are
trying to move up they can't get those
jobs
no okay that does make sense yeah and
like that's like to me that's so why why
do when they march the streets and they
act like they're
they're
fighting for the little guy they're
saying oh we're doing this for poor
people but that's not what happens my
parents run a business yeah if you jack
up the prices they either go to other
countries and hire people
or
or they just don't they figure out how
to hire less people or get it you see
the mcdonald's here the kiosks
that too just get robots to do because
you don't have to pay robots and it's
the same people that say oh i'm doing
such a good job i'm helping out poor
people but they're not doing [ __ ]
they're just making it better for
themselves essentially
man
that's that's interesting one funny
thing that i wanted to say that i
noticed about him because he was like
because the um the interviewer had given
his accolades and his backgrounds and
then he was like i'll make one
correction and he went through it to
like whole life story and i'm like
that's one thing that's one thing about
old black people they're going to give
you every single detail about their life
it's like you could give like the big
points but they're going to say i walked
here five minutes and i turned left went
right then i walked five minutes that
way i spun around and i'll give you
every single little detail i love it i
love it
you'd have to have a
request go up the chain of command to
the secretary of labor he would then
confer with the secretary of agriculture
it would come down the chain of command
and
the department of agriculture to whoever
has those numbers and so on i said good
well they say a journey of a thousand
miles begins with a single step so i
will now submit my request to the
secretary of labor which i did
and i am still patiently awaiting this
reply
and the institutional fear of the number
was what that
oh the us department of labor
administers the minimum wage law
and i and the uh money and the careers
of perhaps a third or some other
significant percentage of the member of
the labor department's resources come
from administering the minimum wage law
one of the real farces of all this is
that the law itself section 4-d i still
remember requires the labor department
to study the employment effects of
minimum wages and those studies are
absolutely a farce
in fact some years after i left i did an
article saying why those
those uh studies were a farce and when i
came back later on to the labor
department to do some research one of
the older librarians who remembered me
turned to the younger librarian and she
said this is the man who wrote that
article that has everybody up in arms
so you became you began to be dissuaded
about of marxism and of government of
government in general because the the
the government uh is not out there at
the personification of the national
interest right they have their own
interests and the labor department was
clearly an interest in
keeping the minimum wage because that's
that's their jobs and careers all right
and power in your which brings us if i
may to one of my favorite books your
2000 book this is a beat up old copy
this book conflict of vision yes which
you published in 2007 and you lay out
i'm sorry 1987. i beg your pardon
reprinted in 2007.
well beat up as this book is it turns
out this is the reprint sorry 1987
and you lay out two
competing ways of looking at economics
and policy really two competing ways of
looking at life that go back at least
200 years
the constrained vision
and the unconstrained vision
the constrained vision i'm quoting from
a conflict of visions sees the evils of
the world as deriving
from the limited and unhappy choices
available given the inherent moral and
intellectual limitations
of human beings close quote
so the constrained vision under itself
understands itself as
constrained by the limitations of
reality itself yes is that yeah that's
correct yes okay
in other words they cannot proceed as so
many do that good things happen
automatically but bad things are
somebody's
fault got it
for that if someone has a constrained
vision do you think that they can
change their vision
i don't know if that's something that he
talks about is how you can go from like
a constrained vision
to
seeing things
non-constrained
yeah i mean some people switch like
people
because
i think no guys i'm not
i could be butchering this but from my
understanding it's like
it's kind of like when you hear people
talking about how everything's the
world's fault okay so that's like
basically a constrained vision is saying
like the world is the cause of my
problems
okay so it's kind of like not taking
like
accountability yeah so it's like me
saying oh i'm a girl
i can't like all these bad things happen
to me because i'm a girl okay and this
this this i think guys correct me in the
comments if i'm wrong but that's i'm
pretty sure all right
that's interesting because
it
it's interesting because there's people
that live their life like that like oh i
can't do this this and this because
i am
whoever i am
but
you shouldn't put yourself into
a box and like i can't do this because
it's like no you can it's just going to
be harder there's going to be restraints
because
of whatever situation you're in if
you're
if you're going into more so a male
dominated company or male-dominated area
and you're a woman is going to be harder
and vice versa and if you
look different if you're different
ethnicity and this and third and you
haven't nobody's been in that sector of
whatever it is it's going to be harder
because either you're the first to do it
or you're
in a bracket where not a lot of people
have done it but just to be like i can't
do it
because i'm this it's like you're not
even trying is this your ar you're
already giving up before you even give
yourself a chance and you know what i've
noticed the people that do break
barriers and those sort of things they
never really bring it up
because they don't look at themselves
like like through that lens and it's
interesting because an example i thought
of is when we did that show we're
talking about consumer debt
you remember when we i we did that live
show
and and they were like oh the reason
women have bad credit is because we just
want to look like better it's society
all this stuff but instead of just
saying no we spend too much and make
poor buying choices you're upset yes
like that's that's from the world view
versus like an individualistic view okay
gotcha that does make sense it's like
you're
you're pointing
the blame somewhere else instead of kind
of taking responsibility for your
actions
okay
got it and then to continue here the
constrained vision
again
quoting from a conflict of visions
for the amelioration
improvement of the human condition the
constrained vision relies on
certain social processes
such as moral traditions
the marketplace or families
not government
so explain that
why why do we rely why do we rely on
so oh shoot okay one is looking at the
government for the solution okay one is
worth looking at family for solutions
okay so do we kind of like swap those
no it's like it's the same sort of thing
so they would say okay then women need
special grants
because he's looking for two
different actions four solutions yeah oh
so it's like it kind of goes with the
world view though because on like one
hand like back with the consumer debt
like decision they would say oh so girls
need higher credit abilities so we need
this from we need more bailouts from the
government or the right where the other
side would say oh you spent that money
it's your own damn fault and like go to
your family go to your go to your family
for help with that stuff don't don't go
to the government
okay that makes sense yes that does make
sense
on processes
rather than the will of the people
instituting changes to improve our
condition
well
it doesn't ignore government
even for the market the work you have to
have a government as uh europe
discovered when the roman empire
collapsed and the economy has collapsed
also
but i guess
one of the reasons would be that with
the government you have surrogate
decision makers and they cannot possibly
know as much as the individuals whose
personal decisions have been preempted
i see
i will agree with that
wholeheartedly um something that
i just was in discussion with with like
friends and family during this
um
last election or
electing voting people into the office
and all that good stuff
was how can
someone
make a law for
um like low-income people when they
don't understand what it is to be in
that situation
and
it's kind of like if you
if you don't know the situation you can
empathize with someone but you're not
going to physically understand what it
is to be
in
a certain situation whatever it is
and so that was just like
part of the conversation i had and it's
hard to be able
to
be like okay yeah i understand when you
may
you may emotionally understand what it
is to be in like a harsh situation but
mentally and physically
if you've never been in it you're never
going to
fully understand it
this was there a law you were talking
about i cannot remember off the top of
my head it was it was just like amidst
um election time and
it was talking about the people that we
were electing i
can't remember okay i was just wondering
if it was like a specific law if i
remember that i'll be like yeah what's
this
right now my brain's like
i see all right which brings us to the
unconstrained vision
when again i'm quoting you when rousseau
said that man is born free but
everywhere in chains
he expressed the essence of the
unconstrained vision which the in which
the fundamental problem is not nature or
man but institutions yes would you
explain that one well he has the notion
that uh again that that good things
happen naturally
i have to bare things it's because uh
institutions including civilization
itself have have made these bad things
happen
and of course uh so it's kind of like
like again back to the credit example
like oh it's society
so in that example like the
like the way he's talking like it's like
society is making us do these spending
habits and i would save if it wasn't for
society okay does that make sense
and i think that that's really the uh
the implicit assumptions behind a lot of
things that are said on the left today
uh and
why in my most recent book i go to a lot
of trouble to show that uh
in nature uh there's nothing resembling
equal opportunity that wherever you look
around the country around around the
world
you find people who live up in the
mountains poor and backwards even in the
richest countries
including the united states
i believe the the poorest country in the
united states the county rather
uh was in a mountain community
uh which was almost 100 white
somewhere in appalachia west virginia
had a life expectancy 10 years less
than men
in a county in virginia
and the constrained the unconstrained
vision says let's fix that we surely we
can pass a law that would improve that
and the constrained vision says well now
wait a moment
if people who live in isolated pockets
and mountains are poor and backwards all
around the world and we see this pattern
over and over and over again maybe
there's something very deeply rooted in
reality about that
that's hard for us to get at correct yes
all right
so in the book a conflict of visions
you're very dispassionate and very
analytical
and you lay out the unconstrained vision
and you lay out the constrained vision
and you don't really come out blazing
in favor of one or the other no
yeah that is not a book meant to commit
to uh
show one vision
is better than the other it's there to
show you what what they are and what
you're assuming if you if you go one
direction or another okay and it's to
encourage people to understand the
implicit assumptions behind all this
without which you you're just a
lot at luke
would you say that the government um in
the states is more
constrained or unconstrained
i think it depends on the state
i think texas is more unconstrained i
think california is more
constrained okay
i can see it yeah
it's
it's so like hard because you
you want to be able to like
depend on the government to
help out everybody but in the grand
scheme of things
it's just not going to happen i think
the problem is there's unintended
consequences like they say the path to
hell is paved with good intentions so
i'll give you an example in california
um in california they wanted to help the
homeless population
so they gave out they're giving money to
homeless people people that are homeless
and that resulted in people moving to
california to be homeless
wow yeah and there's a guy on the um
that they recorded he was like being
interviewed and he literally tells them
he's like i'm a crackhead i moved from
texas to california so i could be
homeless because they pay you to be
homeless here it's great i get 600 bucks
a month to just yeah
right now
i know
i'm about to be homeless
i don't i got a home when i go back but
you see like so so again it's these
people saying oh i know what's best so i
know what's best for these people that
i'm not
and i'm i'm gonna pat myself on the back
oh look at me i'm helping the poor
wow unintended
intentionally hurting people that
actually are functioning members of
society because now they have to deal
with all these homeless people
that
that is
that makes a lot of sense first of all
first of all
six hundred dollars a month
for be homeless
it's
it sucks
to know that that's the thing because i
i literally would pack up everything
like i'm homeless like yo give me my 600
a month thank you
um
but they say that
the homeless in california are more
privileged than
any other like homeless population
anywhere else because they are in
california and it's mind-blowing like
you can be a privileged
homeless person
well and it's it's funny because maybe
it seems mean to say no you can't be on
the street
but
it's it's not because it makes them
figure something else out
is this and some people don't like now
if someone's homeless
and
they wanted to
get on get on their feet now they can be
like well
i don't have to have responsibilities
don't have to work and i'm getting 600 a
month i'll just stay homeless like in
california
they have areas where they have built
houses
tent houses and they'll have tvs they'll
have
cabinets they'll have everything just on
the sidewalk chilling like it's an
outdoor home i remember i told my mom
that she said that's not fair they can
be out there they got to pay rent that's
not fair that they can live out there on
their own and
just take up the sidewalk space like no
they're going to have to pay something
to be able to do that and i was like at
first i was like no like they're
homeless they can't do that what are
they gonna do and now i'm like oh yeah
you all live here
and make things higher i'm sorry and
you're getting six hundred dollars a
month
you better
chip in somewhere because everything's
hiking up and you know who they take it
from you yeah because it comes out of
your taxes
and that's how people don't like another
example i could think of is they
surveyed people and they said do you
care about the environment okay like do
you want to see the environment improve
people said yes then they asked people
would you be willing to spend 30 out of
your paycheck to help the environment
everyone said no
let them you know what it's gonna die
sooner or later just let it and so but
who are the people patting themselves on
the back the people that aren't the ones
i mean it does come out of their
paycheck too but they're trying to get
elected so they they go up and they get
to say yeah i'm fighting for climate
change i'm this that that but they're in
a higher income bracket they don't care
but it eliminates the middle class
because those are the people that have
to pay for it those are the people it
hurts
nah if you say it you paying if you in a
high tax bracket
it's coming out your paycheck don't take
it out of mind it's just a little chip
on your paycheck it's half a minute like
no you then oh my gosh then there's
there's unintended consequences for that
too
how so okay so let's say you take it
more out of the rich people right
fine maybe we do it a little bit but you
you get too high then the rich people
don't want to invest in society they
don't want to be in the u like people
will move to save their money
like people will move their money
overseas haven't you heard of that yes
but it's because like what like if i if
i'm a rich person and they the i'm in
the u.s i have to spend 50 percent of my
taxes go to the government and i know in
this other country 25 of my taxes go to
the government why would i not move
especially when it's millions every year
and then the problem is like you need
rich people for society to function
because like like leaving let's take my
family right if we moved like
300 people wouldn't have jobs
wow or 200 however i don't know how many
people they employ but like
like and so again it's it's back to that
but you wouldn't know that right because
it's kind of like you're not in that
situation but it's a lot of people like
like making laws about situations they
don't understand and that's why i said
what i said earlier man
just help us out
something rich people
i'm saying all right so
pondering all this i i
noticed something a
column that you wrote this is a couple
years ago
in which you rebutted nicholas kristoff
of the new york times and kristoff
had ascribed the gaps between
african-americans and whites in america
gaps in wealth gaps in educational
achieve the usual gaps
to and this is a quotation from kristoff
to the lingering effects of slavery
close quote oh yeah and here's tom soul
quote
if we wanted to be serious about
evidence
we might compare where black stood 100
years after the end of slavery with
where they stood after 30 years of the
liberal welfare state in other words we
could compare hard evidence on the
legacy of slavery with hard evidence on
the legacy of liberals close quote and
so there it is life is hard you use the
word hard
you use the word serious you use
evidence
tom saul is a man of the constrained
vision through and through and through
correct yes
no no
yes you know
part of a vanishing breed i might i so
when so when you were a marxist
the notion explain that because the mark
marxism
well but no no yeah so that's probably
when i was a marxist i had the same
intellectual standards right
he may explain that quote a little bit
more but um
as a black person
i will i will say that there
obviously there are effects causing
effects to everything i will say that
there
are
effects from slavery that happened in
the states but there are
now i believe that there are
so many ways that
black people can be advanced in the
world yes there are still things that
are
in play that
keep us in a certain situation it's
harder for us to get out but i feel like
now there's more
opportunities
for us to get out and
there's a lot of people who
who stay in that mindset like oh
we're in this situation we're
stuck in this area we can't get out we
struggled here we struggled there
trust me my family struggled
from
day one struggle struggle trouble
struggle
but it didn't stop me and my family or
me me and my siblings from doing what we
wanted to do going to college being able
just to live our lives and there's some
people who
don't
release that thought of like
this is going to be hard for us we can't
do this
and they stay there and so
i would agree obviously i would agree
with that quote like there there are
things that just happen in the world
that
we can't control and it's just a lasting
effect like you were saying earlier with
the tax bracket
there's effects to
there's effects to anything and
everything that you do whether it's good
or bad but in that
i feel like you have to
if it negatively affects you how can you
bounce back if it positively affects you
okay how can you
take that and run with it
yeah i agree
and that that's what eventually led me
away from it
[Laughter]
you can see this one
[Music]
um no it's just like um
i think that
i don't want to say that no i know
so
i i like having like conversations like
this with the other side
because i'm interested i'm interested to
just to see just to hear like what
what are
your thoughts about
like this
yeah the effects okay it's more like of
course there's gonna be effects like
that that happened for
how long i don't think 400 years yeah
but it's more like what can you do about
it you can't you can't do anything about
it now like in 2022 so the only thing
you can do is try to be bet like
make right going forward i don't think
like like they'll talk about reparations
and stuff okay so reparations um
i've seen on a lot of videos like when
when the law was passed that
there
no slavery abolished it
there we were supposed to well not me
the slaves were supposed to get uh 40
acres of meal and i remember asking my
mom like who agreed on that why 40 acres
in a meal and she like was telling me
like well back in the day 40 acres you
had your own land and a mule you were
able to
put crops and be able to um
plant and
have have land to do that and so
now i've seen people calculated like
well if we go back and we
talk about we get the 40 acres enemy and
then like they calculated like what else
would we get now and like
um
what's the word um
when interest
they've taxed interest on it and they're
like
we're old like a lot of money i'm like
if that was true today
i would be a i'll be rich person if we
got reparations so
um
i don't know if that's possible or if
that's ever going to be a thing
but
so okay so
the the problem with reparations is what
what percentage of white people do you
think actually owned slaves
in the u.s
i don't
i don't know
it's less than one percent
really yeah
and the other problem is money doesn't
solve poverty
if money solved poverty then like people
could just throw money at a poor person
and they'd become rich but lottery
winners
they're like they go broke faster than
anyone because they don't know how to
spend it yeah it's about like managing
money and being able to run a business
like i think reparations possibly at the
top like at the time but you can't
like like how you're making people that
didn't do anything pay for something
their great great great grandparents did
even if you did the direct descendants
like most people immigrated here after
slavery
like my like i have a grandparent from
lithuania or a great grandparent oh
you're saying that
okay okay like and you have to
understand even and then what about the
white people that fought on the other
side
that fought against yeah
so it's it's almost like like i just
don't know how that would work it's like
you're i understand what you're saying
it's like you're grouping
everybody
all the white people together
when it's like
my my descendants to have nothing to do
we were
we were elsewhere when all this stuff
was happening yes okay i could
understand that yeah
and so i just i just don't know how they
would do it in a way that would like
make sense
like back then sure sure and then you
have to understand like how many people
really owned plantations that was really
only the super rich people in the south
everywhere
what i said you go in the south they're
everywhere no i know but who owns them
that's what i'm saying like like it's
not the majority of people back then
yeah most people lived in the north like
because you have to think about how many
like that was a lot of land so you had
to be a landowner yeah so that's like
the one percent back then
okay
so i'm glad you said that i got my mind
thinking it's not bad
it's not no it's not the internet
scares me a little bit
but it's it's good to have these
conversations like people want
people want like
to have these conversations but it's
like they're not
open enough to be able to sit down with
someone and say this is my opinion on a
hard topic like slavery this is my
opinion it's like well how can you say
that when this happened there was like i
just want to hear what your thoughts are
and then you get me thinking and i get
you thinking it's like okay i never
thought of it like that because if we
honestly if we did have
reparations today i think a lot of a lot
of black people would be out of tough
situations but i also think
a lot of black people put themselves in
worse situations because they don't know
how to manage money and if like the
first steps if they were like okay we're
going to give you reparations but you
have to go through
a class where it teaches you how to
properly manage your money because once
it runs out
we ain't giving you no more we nothing
and so i think that would be
a great first step to be able to
if if reparations was a thing
to be able to
help
the black community i just i don't see
government handouts helping like
a little bit right i think like maybe
initially but it i don't see evidence
that that's super helpful because you
take the homeless population how many of
them are using that 600 a month to like
pocket or
invest in something like over a certain
age i think if you're
if you're homeless like you you've made
choices to get there and i have
relatives that are homeless and the
reason they're homeless is because
they've stolen from every family member
that's let them
like live with them
and then nobody wants to take care of
them anymore and now they're homeless
and i know maybe like a lot of people
are going to say like that's i i come
from a very privileged position i
totally do
but i just think you know you get out
the house at 18 if you're 45 and still
in that situation you did something
wrong the past 20 years you couldn't
have been good with money yeah
yep i agree with that wholeheartedly
because i have conversations with my
family like if we're in the same
situation next year we did something
wrong like if
you're if you
are put into a position and you
there are steps to where you can change
your situation but you don't decide to
change that means you don't want your
situation to change at all yes there may
be obstacles in the way you may have to
jump through some hoops it may be harder
but
i feel like everyone has the opportunity
to change their situation well it's kind
of like you right like
why are you doing this youtube channel
right now because you showed up on time
and you were helpful and so i said like
come on and now and now i pay you to
come on
right so it's like that's an opportunity
that you got because you showed up on
time
yeah and helped out early when no one
else was really helping
and so that's what like i i just i kind
of have a pessimistic view of people in
general i think most people like
don't show up and they don't try
and like and i think you can see it in
the us at least because most people get
overweight over time yeah and that's
that's a direct indicator of how much
you try
i think
you think that's wrong
i don't know if it's a direct
indicator
because
i'm trying to like think
i think it's
a source yeah one of them right one of
them
yeah it's like discipline on some level
because i've been over 200 pounds i've
been big and it was because i wasn't
trying hard enough at losing weight
it's just an indicator that
like you said discipline you don't have
discipline
oh i see in other words i did i hadn't
done all the research i hadn't gone
around the world
looking for evidence yes yes okay
so
and so socialism is a great idea
that does not mean it's a great reality
one of the things that disturbs me
tremendously is about this enthusiasm
for bernie sanders and socialism at a
time when people are literally starving
in venezuela an oil-rich country
you know
and you know they're breaking into in
the grocery stores to try to get food
and they're fleeing to neighboring
countries most of which are not all that
prosperous themselves but there but at
least you don't starve to death in them
uh and none of that makes a bit a bit of
difference
i don't think most of these people who
are out there cheering for bernie
sanders have given a thought to
venezuela to the evidence that's right
to the evidence yeah all right
which brings us to
something that you refer to in a number
of columns you as the retrogression the
experience of african americans in this
country
economic progress i'm quoting you
despite the grand myth that black
economic progress began or celebrated
with the passage of the civil rights
laws and the war on poverty programs of
the 1960s
the fact is that the poverty rate among
blacks
fell from 87 in 1940 to 47 percent in
1960
but over the next 20 years the poverty
rate among blacks fell another 18
percentage points this was just the
continuation of a previous economic
trend
but at a slower rate of progress
it was not
some grand deliverance close quote
that is so counter
to what we are taught in school what
appears on the editorial pages of
newspapers
that i have i feel as though i want to
ask you you really want to stick with
that
that assortment i
i have more than in my most most recent
book that discrimination and disparities
i point out that this really is a
pattern not continuing to blacks or even
to the united states that you can see
the same thing in england you can see it
in any number of other countries that
the poor were or were much worse off
economically let's say in the first half
of the 20th century
and yet they
in terms of their own behavior
they were they had they were far more
decent
societies
uh
and and afterwards after after this
welfare state that's supposed to make
them better off and and better human
beings that's when the crime rate
skyrocketed on both sides of the
atlantic
uh the british were not famous for being
perhaps the most polite
considerate society in the world
prior to that
uh after that you get things like the
2011 riots over there in london
manchester united where they were
they're going through this they they
they
anticipated ferguson uh and
and uh baltimore
by a few years and the same thing is the
the the burning down of buildings the
throwing of gasoline bombs
the whole smear
uh and none of those people were
descendants of slaves
so so that
i'm trying to understand so he was
saying that
as the
poverty level
decreased
the crime level increased
um i think he's saying that when they
introduced the welfare state
okay and before the 60s like
people were poorer but there was less
crime and they were more polite and they
they acted more like decent in society
okay but then after the 60s or 70s when
the welfare state was introduced
so that was when um
they were he's probably going to get
into this in a second but like they were
incentivized to take the data out of the
home because they would give money so
again that was a that was the intention
was let's help the single moms that are
struggling so then but then what's the
government doing they're incentivizing
people to be single moms they're paying
you
per kid okay i
i do understand sorry guys i'm a little
slow you know
they use big words i'd be like
i like understand it but then i need
like another like explanation but i i do
understand that because
where i read it at there was a certain
point where they did
take the fathers out the home
and
i don't i don't understand why
and i don't know if it was because like
oh you getting a sentence from
government if the father's not there i
can get paid bet cool
but
in the grand scheme of things it's not
helping and
it's just
a tactic that started and has continued
for years now and it from the inside out
has just
i would say
taken a toll on the black community and
i wish i wish things like this
information like this was taught in
school
so
people would know like what what
actually happened what
what was going on and why these certain
things happen instead of just like the
overarching theme like oh there was this
there was that and this is why this
happened yay great
but i think like if that was taught
then people would have people be able to
think differently and have a different
view and those laws wouldn't be able to
control people you have to think about
like when you when i look at a policy
you have to like i always say this you
have to think about it in the extreme
what is it incentivizing people to do so
if you give money to homeless people
from the government more people are
going to take advantage of it and it's
the same thing it doesn't mean all
people will because there's good people
and bad people but when you give people
the opportunity in a society to do the
wrong thing more people do it especially
when there's money involved
and i've heard of people having a kid so
they can get more money from the
government yep it's a thing like that's
so imagine being that kid
i couldn't i don't care how much money
i'm getting from the government i'm not
i'm not about to take care of a kid have
a kid no we're childless guys period
childless single but we don't want kids
but
it's it's
irritating to
that that's a thing that
you you do something because you know
you're going to get money from it but
you don't think about
the consequences or the how it affects
the other people that come in especially
in the kid's situation when you
say oh i know i'm gonna get this type of
money i don't wanna get um
i forgot what the word is but they get
mom's benefits to where they are able to
buy things it's like yes that's great
you're helping the single mom but if
your i your thought process was to
have a kid so i can get money so i can
be ballin it's like you're putting that
child in jeopardy and you're teaching
that kid like oh you don't need to do
anything for your own you can just
depend on the government to be able to
take care of you and you'll be fine you
can do exactly what i did i don't
i don't
no i don't like that i think not i think
but you should you should do things on
your own and if it
if you
you should just do things on your own
and not be like i'm just going to live
my life just
for
nothing and just depend on the
government the whole time yes there's
people in certain situations to where
it's like they
can't do nothing but depend
on i don't say nothing but they
have to depend on the government until
their situation change but i don't think
that should be your initial thought like
i'm going to do this i can depend on the
government my whole life yeah but that's
why the government has to make sure
people aren't taking advantage of it and
that's why a lot of times it sounds
harsh especially like
you know the when the wealthy like like
the upper class will say oh no we don't
want government handouts but it's not
because of a lack of empathy like my
parents are very against government
handouts but they've taken in three kids
that were in bad situations that they
didn't they weren't looking to adopt
they just found the kids in bad
situations
but
did i put this like the issue is is from
a policy perspective you can't give
people too much free [ __ ] because
there's unintended consequences that you
don't you don't initially think about
and then it's the same thing
those politicians will say i fight for
single mothers i fight for the lower
class but they're they're killing these
community they're like tearing apart
communities because there's more and
more
single mothers because they know that
they can get benefits so you have more
and more young women
not thinking about the consequence of if
i have if i have sex with this man
there's a possibility i may get pregnant
but it's so it it makes it essentially
easier like oh it's okay i know that i'm
gonna get money from the government but
they don't think about
the child's life
their life and how it affects it as a
whole but
in the end i get money from the
government so that's all that matters
and then the other person like do you
know single women older women are the
biggest like increasing sector of
homeless people
really yeah because they and it's um sad
i hear a lot of girls talk about how
they they're like afraid to settle down
with a guy because they know they have
to take care of their mom someday
because of the choices she made
and they don't want they can't see their
mom get homeless
that's a d yeah because at some point
like the the free ship from the you need
2.5 million to retire
people need to be married like you you
can't do it on one income
and so you have all these single moms
that
they're not prepared and then it takes
one cancer diagnosis to put them on the
streets
wow
oh and this is all from an unintended
this is all a consequence from someone's
who said let's help single moms
and it's
effectively destroyed a lot of different
communities
you can't ones you can't unsee it oh my
you cannot see it oh my goodness oh
poor people were doing if the the lesson
of the 20th century is something like
poor people including in this country
african-americans
were improving their lot and leading
fundamentally decent lives until the
government decided to help them yeah yes
that's that's a fair statement
they're better off
economically because of what's been
given right but of course when you when
you have the crime rate
i mean i i got i got the first inkling
of this some years back when i was a
at some school in harlem doing some
research
and i looked out the window and i
mentioned in passing that when i was a
little kid i used to walk my dog in that
park
and looks of horror came over the
students faces
nobody in his right mind would have a
child going to that park
walking a dog or not
the principal was warning these students
not to cross this park which is about a
block a half wide
even in groups of six
uh when i and when i tell them about how
in this hot summer nights i would sleep
out on the fire escapes in harlem
they looked at me like i was a man from
mars people were doing that all over new
york they were doing it in philadelphia
washington wherever i've known people
that was a common thing for portland we
didn't have the money for air
conditioning right you slept out on the
fire escape or in the parks where walter
grew up in a walter williams walter
williams grew up in a uh
a housing project in philadelphia he was
saying on the hot summer nights the
people would be
in this project have little balconies
they'd sleep out on the balconies and
the ones on the first floor who didn't
have balconies would sleep out in the
yard
and that they were old men who would you
could see sit on a hot summer night
sitting outdoors into the wee hours
playing cards or
or checkers or whatever it was a
different world
[Music]
infinitely safer now what about family
structure
you would think
that
having
being more like
economically like wealthy and getting
help from the government it would
essentially
make people's
their you would be see a better way of
life
but to hear him say that when
they weren't getting handouts from
the government where they weren't
getting government benefits it was
essentially better and safer and it
changed when this is like
i'm trying to wrap my head around and
understand like
why
why is that because money doesn't fix
problems that's that
but like
how many nba players go broke a lot
those are those are guys that get to
live a better life than like anyone in
history they get
they get to be young and wealthy which
is rare
most people if they are wealthy they're
old so they get to experience their
youth
as many women as they could possibly
want
and and half of them go broke because
they they're it's like quick money and
and i just think
like
it doesn't it doesn't solve your
problems like they always say money
doesn't
change who you are it shows who you are
so
yeah
wow
what
okay so with that
that quote
oh my brain is like everywhere right now
because
it's
it's hard to
to know that
before the government stepped in and was
like hey we're going to
essentially help out this community
where where would where would we be now
where would black people be now if that
never had happened would
we be
less than where we are now or
better they were economically outpacing
white people before like they're growing
like yeah
and one of the one of the minimum wage
laws actually the the biggest
in california one of the first minimum
wage laws actually disproportionately
affected young black teens
because what did it do like a lot of
people say it was racist
because instead of hiring the teenagers
and that was like one of the most like
that was
the people that were the most affected
because that's that's what happens you
you work your way up to a higher income
yeah wow
and so yeah and it's crazy because
it's really hard to explain this to
people because they really make you out
to be you see how they paint
conservatives in the media
like it's not
they they they make you out to be like
oh you're not helping poor people when
like honestly
conservatives are like the most giving
people they just do it privately oh it's
not like they're not leaving your face
well because people are more charitable
the more money they make
they just not not to the government so
like when people like like even with the
um with the environment like the one of
the number one indicators that a
community is going to care about the
environment is that they make money like
that the economic prosperity that's why
you see like rich neighborhoods it's
nice
because when people have money when
you're poor like you don't have time to
care about other people
you're trying to figure out yourself
yeah yeah but that's that's where you
get these like huge donations a lot of
the time
interesting because i know
if i was up in that tax bracket i'd be
like oh yeah i would be more willing to
give out money here and there to help
people but but you also i'm going to
tell you the other side of this people
like because when you're when you're
wealthy when you're wealthy
people really take advantage of it like
and this is coming from up from like
i've seen my parents get backstabbed by
people that we have let them live with
us
we have let them because they'll just
think oh they're rich it doesn't matter
and like like we had a nanny we were
employing her
we
we we were paying like she was going on
trips with us she had all this [ __ ] hits
the hand that feeds you because she she
stole like they she bought a laptop off
of like on their credit card oh wow and
it wasn't a lot of money to them right
but it's not about the money it's like
they're principally yeah it's like it's
the respect thing and
that's
that's the problem it's like a
double-edged sword
like because you want to be and and we
are like you know i mean they took in
three kids that weren't theirs but it's
just like
it's i i think it's part of human nature
to be honest to see how much you can get
away with yes yes it is
man i'm still stuck on that quote you
said earlier
oh
well just
you can't see it
most black children were being raised in
two parent families in 1960.
30 years after the liberal welfare state
the great majority of black children
were being raised by single parents yeah
how what what what's the what how does
that by the way we should note that
and okay because before there was a
consequence
and this is in society if you take away
the consequences to every anything more
people do it before if you were a single
mom you damn near where may be homeless
okay so so people were a lot more scared
to get pregnant
you know it's crazy there were less
single moms then and it was easier to
get pregnant there was birth control no
birth control yeah so it's like easier
for us to avoid pregnancy yeah and there
was less of them then
how what do you think that there was
less because
a lot of the men were
off at war i mean was there more my
history is horrible i don't know
do you think that it was less because
the men were
essentially doing more or weren't at
home as
much
do you think that's
why do you think
no i think i think again it's you they
took away the consequence of being a
single mom if you were a single mom
before you were [ __ ] out of luck
and now and now the government yeah they
give you money
so
so before it was you you'd be afraid of
being homeless now there's no fear
because they take away the consequence
oh this video is gonna make my head
explode
and the thing with money showing who you
are like if if you got rich tomorrow
like i i think you'd probably
live a little like you'd probably spend
a little bit more
but are you
i'm
if i got rich tomorrow i would act like
i have no money still no i'd probably be
able to like go out to eat a little bit
more splurge a little bit treat myself
but
i would
essentially for me i think i would act i
would act the the same and it wouldn't
be like oh i'm wearing the designer
stuff like no i have clothes i'm still
going to keep them but like the things
that i want that i know like
if i got them now i would hurt in
another area i would be able to be like
okay i can get that i can get that i can
get that and get that and essentially
make things
better for
any situation that i wanted to and i
would be able to help out my
my family but i wouldn't
yeah cause that's who you are and it's
the same thing with me like i'm not
gonna buy designer clothes
but i i would buy a second soundboard
send money
if you're in premiere
if you're in premiere send money please
please go to the uh pregame show super
chats please
pat moynih patrick moynihan publishes
the moynihan report in 1965
and he's alarmed because the
illegitimacy rate among black families
is 25 then
now among whites it's over a third
hispanics it's over half and among
african americans it's over 70 percent
what's going on there
well this is how again this too you find
the same thing in britain you find it in
uh
france and norway you find it in the
western world
uh and in fact uh there's a solution of
the family structure oh yeah there are
any number of western nations
where forty percent of the children are
raised with with only one parent right
uh at the extremes
compared to
asian countries
at the extremes of iceland it's two out
of three
uh children are born are raised in a
single-parent home uh in south korea
it's one out of 66.
wow
wow
and so what
that's the welfare state what yes it is
are you you're paying you you're
creating a situation where if the uh
first of all the
well you're cr you're creating a
situation where if the man stays there
the the governor will not give them give
the woman welfare
uh and if he leaves he he uh it will and
so they're paying they're paying when
you pay people not to get married more
people don't get married right
it's so simple but yet it's so like
because you're not really taught this
you're not at all you just think oh the
the idea that i had about welfare is
that if you if you're struggling or if
you can't afford something that's when
you get on welfare and that's it and a
funny thing
there's a movie called kingdom come and
there's a um
a scene where um
loretta divine she's the actress and her
son i cannot remember his name but it
was the um
the oldest son in uh
family matters have you seen family
matters
and so
she
she's a church-grown woman and so she
was he was telling her like yeah i'm
gonna find me a church-going girl settle
down have a couple kids and then we're
gonna get on welfare and so that's just
that's something that keeps popping to
my head whenever they say welfare and to
un to know
like
what it
it is it's like
welfare it's trash
this is literally the one of the worst
things
that could have been implemented into
the government
right she's going to become a
conservative
and i understand why they don't teach it
in school because if they taught it in
school
then it wouldn't be a thing anymore more
and more people would not
more people wouldn't be single mom more
and more people wouldn't do the things
that
causes them to depend on the government
they're paying you to make poor
decisions
and the people and the people that make
good decisions pay for it like my dad my
dad okay my dad was
was like poor like he grew up one of 13
kids wow he he south side of chicago
well half his childhood he spent in like
rural
wisconsin and half in the south i don't
know they'd move every four years i
don't know why wow my grandpa was a fire
my grandpa was a fireman's that's not my
grandma didn't work that wasn't a crazy
good salary right for 13 kids they
should yeah yeah we had 13 kids yeah
firefighter yeah okay so it wasn't like
he grew up rich my dad is a workaholic
he my dad has made every good just like
better decisions that i've even made
like never drank never done drugs
never i think he said he smoked a
cigarette once in third grade and he
didn't like it that was it
he he he married the girl he started
dating in his early 20s
had
seven kids by her grew a multi-million
dollar like did this why does he have to
pay
for someone else's poor decisions he
just chooses because there are people
that just choose not to work
and i'm not against no safety net like i
think there's you know mentally disabled
people yeah they're people with a very
low iq that just can't function in
society you have to think of them but
like like that's that's
because i think naturally i lean more
left because i'm a very empathetic
person and i really i enjoy helping
people so my personality is more left
but when my dad explains this to me i'm
like dad yeah why should you have to pay
for them
yeah as you understand you understand
both
both sides
of it and
it's
my like literally my mind is
everywhere right now with this
information and
i
i literally want to be thinking about
this
all day
and i'm going to sit down and be like
what bro
[Music]
where could
society be
and just like thinking about like the
black community like what
like i i think there is someone i have a
theory that there is someone racist like
behind the scenes that i knew yeah
no no no no like
no no like like i don't know who it was
but because they implement this and it
disproportionately affects the black
community and then on top of that
abortion yeah like that the black
population would be double today if it
weren't for abortion like that is a
disproportionately like that affects
that community and so like how crazy is
that there would be double of everybody
and so on top of that yeah like and and
the person who started planned
parenthood she believed in like keeping
the bloodline pure like she was a
eugenic like like i don't i forget the
word for it but like where where you
believe in like keeping like i don't
know pure blood like whatever if i
didn't know what he said no i don't know
i think it's eugenic like she just
basically believed in basically breeding
and she was like and so they literally
marketed planned parenthood to black
communities
and and they basically succeeded because
the black community would be double
today and like you never hear about this
like i
imagine if nike was founded this way
imagine
imagine if nike had some but but for
whatever reason planned parenthood gets
a pass why
why
oh and it's the same people they say
they're for women's rights
okay so how does how does an abortion
help me
does that make me in a better mental
state but there's a lot of there's a lot
of like
physical stuff that happens when you
get an abortion and it could and mental
and it encourages you to make what bad
decisions it encourages women to sleep
around like they're saying oh it's okay
sleep around as much as you want there's
no consequences for it which is a lie
that's a lie because we release a
hormone men don't when we have sex so we
get attached and they don't
so do that as much as you want even and
get pregnant and there's still no
consequence because you can
get an abortion it's just like
they take away personal responsibility
yo
oh
oh my
jesus
right okay so so what would have
happened
if lyndon johnson instead of becoming a
liberal had remained a crusty tough
skeptical texas texas conservative yes
which is certainly the way he started
his career if he if lyndon johnson had
embraced the constrained
vision
instead of instituting the war on
poverty and the great society and so
forth what would the country look like
today a lot better you would not have
the same rates for crime and so on
because you see you can't have a welfare
state in a democratic country unless you
first have a welfare state vision and
when you buy all the assumptions of that
vision then you're buying a lot of
trouble one of the one of the episodes i
think epitomized it was in france in
this case uh that there were tax knife
attacks by various people from north
africa
against chinese people in uh in some
suburbs of paris
and one of the
things that
the attacker said you know that
why are you attacking the chinese and it
wasn't because anything the chinese had
done to them he said they have nice
clothes and big cars that's not fair
i mean that's you know
egalitarianism as a philosophy is one
thing but the actual consequences of it
are mean things like uh resenting other
people's good fortune right
so i wonder
what was it
that this person that implemented this
law what was it about the black
community that they did not like
that they were like
if we do this
this is going to
change the whole trajectory of the whole
community
and negatively affect them but
positively benefit us
i don't know
i don't i couldn't tell you
oh
but you see what he said there with the
hating you hear this narrative well
they'll be like eat the wretch
either like let's tax the re like you
know what i'm saying there's more money
it's like a jealousy thing
yeah and and here's the thing here's the
thing if
let's say what if what if amazon jeff
bezos said you know what screw all you
people i'm done amazon poof gone
and instead of like it would it would be
terrible and we're not even thankful to
these people it's like we hate them why
they're providing a service we all enjoy
literally everybody bro i could not live
without amazon everybody would have went
crazy during the pandemic if they didn't
have amazon
but we hate them even though we
benefited
and you'll see it the more you're gonna
because you're gonna see it the more
successful you get people that aren't no
no people that aren't successful are
going to be jealous of you and feel like
they're entitled to
wow
yeah like it it happens all the like all
the time because my parents i swear to
god the nicest kindest most giving
people i know i like i love my parents
but you also grow up seeing people
really take advantage of that and become
entitled wow like we had people we were
funding we were funding their life
my dad would give them like a salary per
year not they didn't even work like a
relative right
they
they i'm not going to say what they did
but they did something like very
backstabbing to my dad
they were family yeah it was the hand
that hand that fed him yeah
because we remember 1 to 13 there's a
lot of yeah yeah but
yeah it's just like like resentment in
comparison it's the thief of joy
and if if this stuff was
i'm just like thinking about if this
stuff was actually like
taught to people at a young age they
would be able to
think differently
and
know that okay
this was implemented for
a negative effect i'm not going to go
down the same route that
they want me to i'm going to strive to
do better but we're not taught that
as
i'll tell you why oh they're okay
because you can't see this because the
schools are in like cahoots with the
government they're the government yeah
so the problem is that they're not going
to teach it to you in schools because
that would require holding schools
accountable
and it's like like it used to be that
people could pick where to send their
kids to school and this this
disproportionately affected the black
community too
because if you were low income you could
still send your kid to a good school you
wouldn't you weren't stuck by that zip
code but now where you're born you're
forced to go to a [ __ ] school no matter
how bad the teachers are and if you
did you hear the story about the mom
that
sent her child to and she
i don't i can't remember she went to
jail but she initially got in trouble
for it yeah and it's like
how do you
want better for your child
but essentially get in trouble for it
but it's like you're not putting anybody
in harm's way you're not doing you're
just sending them to a better school to
have a better life oh my god and this is
what this is what blows my mind so in
chicago okay
they get 13 000. last i checked around
12
thousand dollars per kid so every kid
that goes to a school the government
gives you the 12 13k to the to the city
of chicago okay chicago has terrible
schools you know those better test
scores my school you know what the
tuition is in my school eight thousand
dollars per kid you know the difference
between us and the public schools the
public schools had really nice
facilities they had a beautiful gym all
this [ __ ] okay
my school didn't have any of that we
didn't have air conditioning but they
invested in what teachers
oh wow oh because like a nice gym is
going to make you more educated
so so it's like the the
and
but the problem with teaching positions
is it's like it's there there's no
incentive there's no
if you teach for 10 years you're on
tenure they can't fire you yeah and then
okay and then you're going to see this
differently too because the unions
like teachers unions are basically to
protect teachers from getting fired but
some of them should get fired yeah and
so they'll march the streets and say oh
we're fighting for teachers you're not
fighting for teachers if you're a good
teacher you're not going to be let go
yeah exactly so but it's really hard to
fire teachers especially if they've been
there after a certain time
and no matter how no matter how
bad they are
if they hit a certain mark like tenure
they get to stay and they get to
continually
teach the way they are teaching
and i've had teachers that have been
like why why are you a teacher
why are you here you hate your life when
you're here you don't want to you don't
want to
teach us anything that's actually going
to help us why are you here
and and you know what you know what
would help they used to do charter
schools so you could say okay the 13k
that the government gives the schools
for my kid i want it to go to that
school
and then do you know who would do you
know who would you would see if they did
that you would see business people jump
in
because they're like oh [ __ ] i can make
13 000 as a kid
i'm gonna figure out a way to educate
them in the best way possible so i can
make money like wanting to make money
isn't a bad thing if you're providing a
service that everybody needs but the
problem is the government strong arms
these parents descending like it's not
fair and i say this like if there's one
policy i could like fight for it would
be education equality because that's
like you shouldn't just because you're
born poor you shouldn't be stuck having
a [ __ ] education like i got a good
education because my parents could
afford it that's not fair
yeah like
and so it's like the same thing they
take away the consequence for the school
because no matter how bad of a job they
do
the government still
pays them and the consequence used to be
i'm pulling my kid yeah but now they're
we'll send you to jail
and then the teachers will say oh
let's fight for more pay but it's not
it's about
you
and there was there's a school in new
york that did it because so there are
charter schools a little bit right but
there aren't enough so it's by it's by
lottery basically so it's like it's like
at random you can apply to possibly but
you have to be chosen
and there's a school in new york that
did it they paid all their teachers six
figures
you had people that like weren't even
teachers applying that were just like
really good at music really good because
i think there's so many people that like
i would teach if there was more money in
it
i would and there was some incentive
like where it wasn't just
like if i was better at teaching i would
get more money yeah but
like i would do a youtube course i
totally like there's a ton of kids i
want to do oh yeah yeah sure and
like and i would be good at it too i'd
be really good at but i would never do
it because i don't want to make 45k a
year for like for what no and not and
live off of 10 like it's just not but
the
and at that school they literally
recorded lectures and then after school
they would tell them okay this you say
it this way that's wrong you need to
explain it in that way and like it was
like and like teachers would quit
because it was so stressful but these
kids improved so like there was all
low-income kids that improv like had a
yeah
but why isn't like stuff like that
why isn't that because the way they
market it they market it they say oh
you're not fighting for teachers like
they you like did you remember when the
i don't know if you heard of this but in
chicago there's a really big teachers
like riot and like they're on strike
which is so selfish
like it's not about you it's about the
kids yes exactly like
yes teachers
if you if you
believe if you're i won't even say that
but
essentially it's not
it's not about you if you're
it's about the kids in the grand scheme
of things and
if you're
not it's like like i said my brain is
everywhere right
i work for youtube i can't be on strike
if i'm about strike from youtube i just
stopped getting paid yeah exactly
and and like negotiate with your
employer like figure it or go get a
better like go negotiate with another
school but you're making the kids pay
for this yeah
i never understood a strike brought me
i'm not about to go on strike and miss
money like
yes i may be
it may be low it may not be where i want
it to be but if i'm gonna go talk to
somebody take up take a day off and not
get paid just to walk around right now
no and then go back to work and nothing
changed and i missed a day of work yeah
no i want to tell you once you see it
you can't unsee it
all right so
one response to the gap
again i returned to this gap between
african americans and other americans
affirmative action yes which brings us
back to your alma mater harvard
accordingly i know i'll never live it
down you'll never live it down yes
you once told me that the principal
benefit of a harvard degree was never
again having to be impressed by anybody
who had harvard degrees
absolutely
so
these are figures that were published in
the harvard crimson the student
newspaper in the harvard class of 2019
these are the kids who will be
graduating next june the average s.a.t
score for black students was 21.49
by the way these are all good scores but
for black students 2149 white students
22-18 asian students
2300. well now that must be reasonable
because it's taking place at harvard the
seat
of reason
well well that wasn't quite how i
described it when i was there
affirmative action is that is that
we ought not to be doing this
you know there are various uh
laws and policies that benefit one group
at the expense of another
but i think affirmative action has the
distinction of being one that harms
everybody though in different ways
and so you you there
there's a lot of evidence
that there are black kids who have all
the qualifications to be successes in
college who nevertheless are failures
because they are systematically
mismatched with institutions whose
standards they don't meet even though
they may meet the standards of 80 or 90
percent of the colleges in america
i remember first aware of this when i
was teaching at cornell
why isn't
i wish that was something that was
taught
in school like
these are
your qualifications yes you may want to
go to this ivy school but you'll be more
successful if you go to these schools
because it shouldn't be taught they
should be denied
that's true like you shouldn't be
accepted to a school you're not
qualified for
that's true but then it goes back to
what we talked about last time quota
and
it hurts and and it hurts the smartest
kids too
because that's as he said someone that
goes to harvard even you know that you
have to have some like they might but
they're going to think they're dumb
and they're not they're smarter than 80
to 90 percent of people yeah
it's
there's just so much that
could
positively positively affect
a nation but it's like
why why is it like why isn't it
happening
but i know that if it happens then
people are going to
become more as independent or like be
able to think for themselves and not
have to
depend depend on the government or
depend on this depend on that and it's
going to be less and less of
like a
a hole that
these overarching things have on people
and people are going to be more free to
be a human
and
oh
it's the media i'm telling you and and
the crazy thing is it's the same thing
that's right i hate people that are act
like they're doing the right thing so
the people they're saying oh well i'm
fighting i'm fighting for black people
i'm letting them into harvard i'm we
need these quotas
but if it hurts it hurts yeah if it's
not like yes you could be letting them
in but
if it's not a successful situation for
them how are you how are you helping
them yes on their resume may say harvard
and they may
but if they don't graduate
there's nothing on the resume yeah and
they switch their major like he he might
talk about this in a second because i've
read a couple of his books and and one
of his books
he said like it would i can't remember
but it was a high percentage would
switch their majors from like
engineering to to an art
to or something easier to communicate
graduate yeah yeah do you realize how
many more people would actually
if
if we
if they were
if they went to the schools that they
were more successful at do you realize
how many more people would use their
majors pick a major that they
enjoyed and that they were successful in
and afterwards be able to use it instead
of just picking an easy major just just
to graduate well and then oh my gosh
this is another layer okay another layer
is that the reason there's so much
college debt is because they took away
the consequence like usually
people should be denied for loans that
can't afford loans
but that's that's how it worked before
they subsidized education in the 1960s
or 70 i don't remember what year but
late night
but whenever whenever that happened what
they did was say we're going to give
oh we want more poor people to go to
college right so so let's give all of
them loans
anyone can get a loan regardless and
instead of being denied those loans they
were given loans and now you see people
paying off college debt into their 50s
like that's that's insane and then it
hurts the people later so that's another
problem as to why you see so many people
going to colleges they can't afford and
getting degrees that don't make any
money
and it hurts you know who it hurts the
most to
poor kids because like at least me even
even upper like middle class even even
the kids that like my parents could
afford my college but the kids i grew up
around they knew to get a degree in
engineering math like my my dad
no you can't get a like i i'm doing
communications right but i have an
economics degree
because he was like i'm not paying for a
degree that doesn't have an roi
oh wow
so and you know it helps me a little bit
on the channel still probably more than
a communications degree honestly but
like if you don't have that guidance and
you're 18 sure i'll sign up for college
debt everyone is college that they don't
know any better
how are you supposed to know
and now they're saying oh forgive all
college debt but now what about the
people that did the right thing and paid
it off
yeah
do they get reimbursed for that did you
get their money back
no
and that's crazy what i was just
thinking about like if
if we were taught that go to a school
that you can or if they didn't
ever implement the law like we're going
to give you
any type of loans
and
you went to the school you could afford
went to the school you were most
successful in
in the black community
would there be so many
kids that are
in sports and they think that that
that's their way out and if they don't
play a sport they can't get out would
that would would they resort to that or
would they resort to
i this is a college i can afford this is
a college i know i'm going to be
successful in
and
i'm able to play a sport would academics
come before the athletics
you would think that you would think if
they were taught the numbers because
your chance of going to the league is
slim yeah
my parents always told me like even now
i have a chance i could play pro if i
want in um probably germany or something
my dad tells me it's not a career that's
not your future
you can do it if you want but it's not
your future because there's so there's
so many
that think i'm going to the league i'm
going to the inside like you may be
great great for your high school great
for your college but
it's it's so hard and there's so like
it's such a slim little area to where
that you actually are able to go
to
play in
the league and then if you don't it's
like
devastating you went to college with
this
major that you didn't really care about
but you needed a major because you
needed to play basketball but now like
what what do you have to fall back on
oh and you know what they don't push
either plumbers electricians i'm talking
about that with my mom traits like trade
work it's like
she when she was going to school she was
that was something that was implemented
in school like trade work being being a
plumber being an
electrician hardware and um
welding like those are
well-paid jobs but they're not looked at
as well-paying jobs because oh it's a
plumber like a trash a trash man he made
babies
if i would have known that i would be
out there driving that truck
go to the back of the truck i'd be out
there i'd be a trash woman right now if
i would have known nothing like they
make money anyone like that there's
trash wow
and
it's like
oh
okay all right
and i found a half the black students at
cornell were on some kind of academic
probation
and so i went over to the administration
building look up the sats of these
students the average black student at
cornell at that time scored at the 75th
percentile
which is pretty darn good yes
and so that means that that at most
colleges in this country they would have
no trouble and many of them would be on
the dean's list
but at cornell the average liberal arts
student at that time was in the 99th
percentile and and when you when you
when you're teaching
students like that uh you teach at a
pace
that most people
of any race cannot keep up with and i i
was it was always complained that i was
assigning all kinds of reading
but heck i'm teaching kids who are in
the top 1
they can they they can keep up with it
with the reading that i'm assigning
uh so cornell was taking very talented
black kids and spending four years
teaching them to feel inadequate yes and
succeeded
oh this is
this is not a good video to watch right
now while it's this time of the month
because it's emotional to oh
just like
where could those like those kids that
he was talking about that were on
academic probation
where could they have been if they were
placed in a situation for them to
succeed i'm thinking about just
my friends my family that if they were
put
in a a situation to succeed where would
they be right now right that's why i
think quotas are racist it's white
people saying oh black people can't do
it themselves that's racist
oh that's like that's that's yes it's so
racist saying that you need our hope
yeah you need our help
like the audacity of these people the
audacity but we never look at it like
that it's the same thing like honestly
my in my opinion reparations same thing
you need art we need to say like
like you're not you're not competent
enough to do it yourself you can't you
can't get out of the situation you're in
so you need you need our help you need
reparation that reparation would be nice
it was like
extra money but like you need like you
need you need the government you need us
our help you need the quotas you need to
sat in the third to be able to get out
the situation it's like that is
it may not be taught to us like right in
our face but subconsciously that is
something that's implemented in the in
just society and it's taught us
subconsciously to where
we don't realize we're depending on this
that and the third to be able to get our
situations like we don't no you can't oh
no like
oh
okay we're just gonna keep going
um
a couple quotations this is these are
both from the last affirmative action
case to reach the supreme court last big
affirmative action case to reach the
supreme court 2003 uh grudder versus
bollinger
here's the majority opinion which was
written by justice sandra day o'connor
quote
the court expects that 25 years from now
the use of racial preferences will no
longer be necessary this upholding the
use of in a decision 5 4 decision
upholding the use of racial preferences
now that's quotation 1 here's quotation
2 justice thomas justice clarence thomas
in a descent quote
i believe that blacks can achieve in
every avenue of american life
without the meddling of university
administrators
the court holds that racial
discrimination and admission should be
given another 25 years
while i agree that in 25 years these
practices will be illegal
they are illegal now
close quote
so
here's
what do you do with the argument that
justice o'connor writing that majority
opinion
there's something of the constrained
vision there look we have these all
universities across the country are
using these racial
preferences to as the basis of admission
the best we can hope to do is tell them
they ought not to be doing it that they
should be developing other standards and
give them a give them a clock
is that a reasonable thing to do
no but it's a universal thing to do
i wrote a book
about affirmative action it was called
affirmative action around the world and
i made a couple of uh international
trips at the expense of the hoover
institution
around the world to check on affirmative
action this is one of the one of the
most common arguments that is absolutely
fallacious time and time again the
argument that
likes so much in the unconstrained
vision it assumes that we have a power
that we do not have cannot have and
never had to have had
in england there was a man named skarman
who was saying for the now we must do
this in order to order and in many
countries these pre these programs were
set up with an actual cutoff date
so it was set up with in malaysia with a
cut-off date i think of around
1990 and in pakistan it was like it was
supposed to go for 10 years
none of those
cut off dates has meant
a thing these programs not only continue
they increase they spread so the idea
that you can control for the future
because of these wonderful sounding
words
i can't think of a country in the world
where that's ever happened
in the case of pakistan they did have an
absolute
actual cut-off date
uh and because the people in east
pakistan were for whatever historical
reason way behind the people in west
pakistan and so there's these
preferences with east pakistanis
now before time for this thing to expire
the east pakistanis uh cc from pakistan
and formed a new nation of bangladesh
right and the preferences continued
right on because there were other groups
that had been added to it and so once
you get the constituency you can't say
no to them i see but it is an argument
that that
has never worked out anywhere that i've
been able to to check all right so
tom sol says no to the welfare state no
to affirmative action
what is to be done and now you were kind
enough to share with me
uh the galleys of your forthcoming
edition of discrimination and
disparities let me give you a few
quotations from
some of the the new chapter in that book
quote the poverty rate among black
married couples has been less than 10
percent every year since 1994. as far
back as 1969
young black males whose homes included
newspapers magazines and library cards
had similar incomes to those of their
white counterparts
academic outcomes show a pattern of
disparities similar to the pattern of
disparities
in the amount of time devoted to school
work
apparently
lifestyle choices have consequences yes
close quote
so this is the constrained vision once
again
welfare state that's government we don't
rely on that
affirmative action government we don't
rely on that
we rely on hard work
we rely on the institution of marriage
is that's correct yes in other words
these things i don't think it's the
marriage especially the library cards as
such
it's that there are lifestyle choices
that have been made and and the
comparison i made was between if you
look at the poverty rate among blicks
it was a 22 percent and among whites was
11
but among black married couples it was
7.5 right so it's not so they not only
do better than blacks as a whole they do
better than whites as a whole
and so it's it's so it's lifestyle
choices similarly with with the results
and the some of these are more
successful charter schools
but then you implement the welfare
system and that destroys it
i think there's a stat that say that
says
i'm getting the number partially wrong
but i want to say
18
of men in the black community father 80
percent of the kids
and um half of half of like 45 or 50
of black guys are single childless and
in the middle class
and yet on the media
we see
them painted as like entertainers as
players but literally
it's a very small percentage that
actually is oh
oh my goodness
oh
she's red pilling on camera oh my
goodness my brain is doing
somersaults right now with
yeah
yeah we're just gonna keep doing some
research that's uh you have these kids
not only uh meeting but exceeding the
national standards in places like harlem
and beverage divers in the south bronx
and these are not kids who are
skimming the crown cream they're kids
chosen by lottery
they don't even test them for ability
they don't even look at their academic
records they take them into the schools
and and they and they have hearts the
charter system i was telling you about
yeah that's what he's talking about so
that's what he said they don't test you
it's by lottery okay remember when i was
saying the charter yeah okay at work and
they make it clear at the outset and
they don't tolerate a lot of nonsensical
behavior
uh and and these kids are doing
incredibly so
tom here
again i think back to the moynihan well
no i think so the moynihan report in 65
and he was very alarmed by
the illegitimacy rate of 25 among
african-americans by the way in fairness
to the late moynihan we should point out
one reason he was alarmed by this was
his own his own father had walked out on
the family when he was 10 years old he
experienced what it meant yes to be to
kids to have one parent okay and now
it's all gotten dramatically worse for
whites and hispanics and black for
everybody
and then i think
back beyond that to your experience of
harlem
you drop out of high school and do what
go on welfare start cashing no
you went to work
and you spent some of that money to buy
some inexpensive encyclopedias yeah
and the
harlem was
so
but i feel this uh council it's almost a
council of despair
in that that world just seems so utterly
vanished no question you but so your
argument is if if we can stand up to the
welfare state
we can somehow get back to that world a
family family structure will reassert
itself oh that's going to that that's
going to be reconquering the same ground
which is really tough to do
but it can't it can be done
i was i was so lucky
at the time i had no no clue about all
this as i was thinking earlier i'm like
how
how can a 16 year old high school
dropout
go to college go to a prestigious class
like harvard
get a bachelor's get a master's and a
doctorate
but nowadays if you do that oh your life
is over
like high school dropout like you have
to like have some sort of
something to be able just to move on to
the next level education and it's like
it's mind-blowing as to
how not i won't say simple but how just
like
less complicated it was back in the day
to be able to
before
this implement implementation of welfare
came along and it's like
burn it down take it away i don't want
it anymore i mean i'm not benefiting
from it but
oh
like we actually have a question
do most of the people you know that are
chronically in poverty is it because of
their choices or because of where they
were born
more you have to pick one okay
more i know i know it's both i know both
definitely goes into it
i would say
more of their choices because yes they
were born into a
difficult situation
or a harder situation than normal
but their choices
have
landed them where they are now because
if they would have made different
choices they would be in a different
situation it's interesting i know rich i
know kids from rich families that are in
poverty because they just spend money
they don't have
wow like i know like i i have a
close relative that will always be broke
because he
does not know how to save money he's
always spending money he doesn't ha like
and sure he lives off my pa like
he gets some money from my parents for
now but at some point he's like after
after a certain age he's going to get
cut he'll he'll be broke forever
because he just doesn't
have any discipline or self-control
and you see it in his life because he's
very overweight he's very like it's
usually not just one thing i've noticed
like like some some not everyone
overeats right like they might be but
you just notice it's not like the lack
of discipline is just everywhere
it's a snowball effect one thing and
then it just
builds into another yeah
uh
at the uh in 1948
uh
many decades later i learned that the uh
unemployment rate among black teenagers
in 1948
16 17 year olds
was
9.4 percent
among whites of the same age it was 10.2
percent
so both blacks and white teenagers
had only a fraction of the unemployment
that they have today
uh you were expected to work you were
expected to be able to get a job and
more importantly the jobs were there for
you
uh and so and what this is because of a
fluke really the the the minimum wage
law in the united states fairly
overstandance act of 1938
was passed with specified
rates of pay that you're supposed to get
almost immediately
inflation took off during the 1940s
so by 1948 those numbers that were in
the law were meaningless oh i see you
know there are other words when i
started out as a western union messenger
the minimum wage was 40 cents an hour i
started out at the bottom at 65 cents an
hour so it was the same as if there was
no minimum wage and this is what
happened you had this
i was so lucky i knew of course i had no
clue about any of this
now now a black kid 20 years later comes
in there
uh they've now
they've people have become compassionate
they've raised the minimum wage so he
can't get a job
got it and i don't think it does any
community any good to have a whole lot
of teenage
males
hanging around on the streets with no
jobs and nothing to do
oh my
so many
and it's the same people it's crazy
these same people will say oh i'm
helping communities i'm doing this this
and this and i swear to god jess the
people that do the most say the least
the people that act like they do
everything yes bro they do nothing
even i'm so
oh
i'm thinking about something i'm trying
to like connect it to see if it would be
a thing and what i'm thinking about
is it
would
would there have been
any i won't say any but would there have
been an inflammation of crack into the
black communities if this was something
that
wasn't a thing like would that have
would that have been
an avenue for people to
make money
but illegally and then if this was
implemented they would they wouldn't
have needed to make money legally
because they would have had the job
opportunities to work and then
there wouldn't be
it's kind of weird timing it's kind of
weird it's kind of weird timing how that
happened right around the same time the
welfare state was introduced kind of
weird timing
burned the whole country down cut
kind of weird and you know what's crazy
too i know people
um i know someone that
dealt drugs when they were younger and
you know who got him into it
his teacher
bro
it was like a school
yeah it was like a gym teacher or
something
wow
so it's like literally from
the system that's supposed to protect
you yeah
you know what's crazy that same teacher
runs a dare program now oh bro i know
they're like yeah he changed the name
get him canceled i don't i don't know
the name
this guy just told me that i was like
what the [ __ ]
what
imagine if that person
didn't have a change of heart how many
other
students
i don't even believe he had a change of
heart no i just felt more stupid
oh
i don't i don't believe it for a second
i just think he didn't get caught yeah
people
if
i think if a negative consequence
doesn't happen from a choice a bad
choice you've made you're not going to
do it you're not going to change your
thoughts until it affects you negatively
so if that teacher
never got caught nothing bad ever came
they're still going to do it even though
it is
bad
and i i think the older you get the more
you see people's life choices that catch
up to them the consequences come up but
like there's a lot of [ __ ] that i did
when i was younger because
like that i didn't do because i knew the
consequence
like my dad caught me smoking weed once
in high school he cried
bruh said not my baby girl yeah that was
a crazy thing
he thought i was a stoner
that i thought your life was over
bro i i smoked weed once
and i caught like
like they like the only reason they had
they would have my friends had a picture
of me doing it was because i didn't like
it and so the picture was the weed and
then me going oh okay
and then that's when my dad sees this
picture he's like my baby's a stoner
like no dad your life is over put you in
rehab now i just wanted to try i heard
the food tasted good
but like i didn't like it anyways it
wasn't my thing but like oh my god
i
oh my gosh i i felt so guilty i felt so
bad yeah and like
that it changed like you did something
you had a negative effect think about it
i'm sorry dad
i'm sorry
i didn't mean it
it was just one time thing she's okay
now she's fine living her life out here
yeah
still my brain flipping
right
tom so
but
another thought here
you're describing a world
harlem the urban world
gone yeah
you but you made visits when you were
young you knew the south as well didn't
you did you you you went back to the
south when you were young from time to
time i said back to the south because as
i recall you were born in the south yeah
like
new york went to new york yeah uh well i
i think this was courtesy of the marine
corps which happened to locate the boot
camp in south carolina but what about
camp lejeune and north carolina okay so
what i'm getting at is you were of the
generation that saw jim crow with your
own question no question
okay
so well here's
let me read you a quotation this is from
an article that got a lot of attention
in the atlantic a couple of years ago
called the case for reparations
by tom nahisi coates
quote
white supremacy is a force so
fundamental to america smash or pass
smashing pass
he's a black man i'm kidding pass i
think he's kind of cute he's attractive
he's attracted smash
where you at sorry i know this is a
serious video like light of the mig
light of the moment
that it is difficult to imagine the
country without it reparations is the
price we must pay to see ourselves
squarely close quote
and tom sowell who actually saw jim crow
with his own eyes and experienced it
responds how
it would be nice to know his uh
evidence for what he said
just to be old-fashioned about it
uh
no it was a rotten system
but i don't know how how we get from
that to reparations
i mean
what we see in the united states in
terms of the bad things you see all
around the world
if you were to give reparations to
everyone whose ancestors had been slaves
i suspect that you would have to give
reparations to more than half the entire
population of the globe
slavery was not confined to one set of
races i suspect that most of the people
who either slaves or slave owners around
the world were neither white nor black
i mean this was this was a universal
curse of the human species africa
the middle east asia
and it continued elsewhere
so
i can understand that because if you
give
if you give reparations to
black people
what about overseas
the jews
you have to reference reparations of
them the holocaust you give reparations
to them it's like then
those are the ones off the top of my
head but there's other areas it's like
and i ireland had it too actually it was
i don't know if it was i think they
called it
indentured servants but if you look at
like the life expectancy it was lower
than slaves wow it was
yeah like it happened everywhere
and like
for
for a black person to say like okay
yes i understand that
reparations would be needed for
everybody so like
for
i'm trying to like say it right
it's like
you
it's hard to say like
well everybody should get reparations
like well
this happened that happened and this is
different it was like it's the same
situation because my mom would say that
to me she will always bring up the
holocaust but i'm like but
it's different but it's not
if
if
the world
gave reparations to every single race
that was
done wrong then there it would be more
than just black people and that's
if you're not open to understanding that
is that you're just going to be like no
like
we need it we need it we need it but
it's like
we we don't we don't necessarily need it
because if you depend on it you're going
to be
sitting and waiting for that to come
your whole life and stay in the same
situation that you're in your whole life
waiting for someone to
give you reparations
for something that happened
many many years ago when it's like if
you want better for your life
i literally thought of kim kardashian if
you want better get up and go to work
but if you want better like you can
choose better but it's not
it's just not
like taught to us that you can choose
but i don't say it's not taught to us
but it's more so
that it's
less taught to us like you can you can
choose to do better with your life you
don't have to
follow in the footsteps of everybody
that came before yes they may have done
this done that but you don't have to
choose that life to have a better life
and
yeah
and you know what's oh my gosh you know
what's crazy that
i i hate talking about this because it
just like
i don't clap so
no but like you realize not all slaves
and slave owners had like a bad
relationship it was wrong absolutely but
like there were accounts of like slaves
slave owners or slaves being very loyal
to their slave owners even after slavery
ended like there's accounts of like a
kid that was like the slave owner's son
and um
the son um
like was a drunk and all the slaves like
took care of him even after slavery was
abolished
because it wasn't as simple as like
like if you're born into a family that
has slaves right they can't just let
them go free because then like they'll
be all in poverty like how would they
exist in society like there's writings
of people saying i think this is a
terrible institution but i don't know
what to do
and you know what i'm saying yeah and i
don't i'm not like i'm not trying to
take that away like it was wrong like
absolutely but like it wasn't
there were there were accounts on both
sides it wasn't like every slave owner
was like a terrible person and the
problem is when you look at history you
have to look at it as the side of the
oppressor
that's what they always say if you
really want to understand history
it's interesting you say that there's a
video i saw
and um
it was the this i forgot who was
interviewing but it was a group of white
people sitting down and they were like
i don't i don't know what why people
think that
like
slaves were in chains and this that the
third and they were treated badly
because my
grandparents or like my parents had
slaves but they were treated like they
were regular people and i'm like how can
how can you say that when da da like you
don't know it's like i don't know either
i don't know
where i'm only i only know what was
taught to me and what was taught to me
was
the
bad side of it and now it's like was
there
was there certain situations where
um
where
slaves were
treated
correctly or treated as equal and it's
like if i say that
which i just did it's like how can you
say that you're you're black you you
don't support it's like i i like you
just i know it's bad like yes they're
worse situation but i'm like thinking
like
were there other were there better
situations because like how can you
be
beaten
treated like the scum of the earth and
when you're free
you go back
it's like
it doesn't make sense well because some
people went back to work for them
because it's like okay like the only
reason i know this is because i read
this uh us like a kid that was like born
in slavery and guys people in the
comments probably will know who he was
like i think he died around the 20s or
30s maybe but like whenever he was alive
he was like born as a slave and he he
just gave his like life's experience and
part of it was he was talking about how
like the slaves were very loyal to that
owner because like they they all really
liked him and like took care of the sun
and like um
i i don't it just wasn't
and like even after slavery was over
they all stayed because they were just
loyal to him because if you're born as a
guy like who inherits a plantation
if if you let everybody just go they're
going to be in poverty how would they
exist in society yeah that's what that's
what and the only reason i know that is
because i read the this guy's diary
where he talked about that and the slave
owner is talking about like i think this
is a horrible institution
but if i let everybody go they're gonna
they're gonna be in a worse situation
yeah
but you don't think about that yeah and
because even me saying this makes me
nervous
because i'm not i'm not sweating right
now i'm like jesus no because i'm not
i'm not trying to say it was a good in
any way it was a terrible institution
but yeah
it was and
what they're talking about right now
welfare
i in my eyes from what they're saying
it's a terrible institution because it's
changed the trajectory of
people
and it's it's like but what
what can you do you can't pull out the
rug
from underneath someone right now that
is depending on it until there's like
steps to it's like when a child is
nursing you got to take steps to
this
uh what's the word to
take them away from what they've known
for so long to start feeding them with
the body you just can't be like oh i'm
gonna pop you off and put a bottle in
your mouth like you don't need this
anymore but it's like
they're gonna go into shock and not know
what to do and
i don't know i think that people face
consequences quicker they come up with
solutions quicker
so for example did you know anyone
during covid that didn't work because
the government was giving them money
yes i knew so many people
but the second they stopped with the
payments a lot of them got a job real
quick that is true that is true they
figured it out
and i just think like when it starts to
affect your life you just start thinking
of solutions
no i don't i don't know the answer i'm
not i'm not a policymaker maybe let me
know in the comments
long after
uh it was abolished in the western
countries all right let me try his uh
sticking with tanahisi codes
it's shelby talk shelby steel talks
about white guilt
and in tana he's a coach you get this is
the thing i used to feel so guilty for
being white
oh my god this is this is a thing this
is such a thing when i was younger
especially when i was like in high
school because i was just pushed so much
that like white people are bad white
people this
that was like i don't know do you have
you heard of that or no white guilt yeah
i've yeah i've heard of it
but i'm
i've never talked to it
i've never talked about it to a white
person to be like what do you think
about white guilt yeah because when
they're like talking about all the stuff
that white people did like in schools
and stuff that was bad i'm like
but then i was like i'm not even from
the u.s i'm from my parents my parents
are from lithuania she's like i'm not
even technically i wasn't even there
yeah i don't know who did that but
not the lithuanians it wasn't me
almost the counterpart of that
a kind of
african-american claim against the white
guilt
and this seems
it beginning with the abolitionists even
beginning before the civil war
you see almost every generation there's
some expression
that
racism and slavery shelby calls it this
correctly of course the sin of slavery
is so deeply and it's something we still
live with how do we expiate it how do we
get past it is there something we can do
to relieve ourselves of this legacy oh i
think you should repeat it
if you were a slave owner i i don't see
any reason why you should feel
differently on the other hand
i can't get over the idea of a
apologizing for what b did
okay uh even when they're contemporaries
much less when when one is dead and the
other is alive
all right i mean
scalia i remember saying you know that
uh i i i i owe no man anything
because uh people who look like me
caught did something that people look
like him
okay so just get past it
get to work yeah all right tom sowell's
view is get an education stay married
and do your job
roughly yeah all right charles murray
i'm taking you used to write a column
every so often called random thoughts on
the book
and so i'm giving you a little little
snippets here of the passing scene as in
our final questions charles murray in
his 1984 book losing ground and charles
murray writes about discussions in
academia and government about the effort
to close the gap again between african
americans and whites quote
1984 quote whites had created the
problem
it was up to whites to fix it and there
was very little in the dialogue that
treated blacks as responsible actors
close quote has that changed no it is
not
all right
on on we
to the passing scene your friend your
longtime friend walter williams
now we come to current politics the
bottom line is that president donald
trump does not have the personal
character that we would want our
children to imitate but
save his misguided international trade
policies has turned out to be a good
president
tom
i think his policies have been by and
large have been policies that were far
better than that of previous democratic
or republican administrations
so
i go by the consequences okay i mean he
he hasn't produced the right rhetoric
but the fact is that uh
unemployment among low-income people
black hispanic included uh
uh
is that a level that is far lower than
it's been in decades
i will say this
about
donald trump
he
he ran the country not as a politician
as a from a business standpoint and he
that's something that he's
good at
and
i
that quote that that man said
about his character traits and what he
has
said the inappropriate things he has
said like yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't
want my child to
look like i want to say that i want to
do that just like donald trump like no
his character traits in that sense like
no
but
the policies and the things he
implemented in the country during his
presidency
can't argue with them he you know
i mean it's crazy
nobody painted him as a bad guy when he
was in the media
for all those years everyone loved him
when he was in the media like on tv yeah
rappers brought him into like videos
he wasn't sherlock holmes
people loved donald trump until he was
trying to like do something for society
honestly yeah
and
the media
from
from
my like from what i saw that
it painted
a lot of things like incorrectly
about
what he did during his presidency and
i wish
and it wouldn't probably never be like
this to where media can honestly like
say oh this president did this this
president did that
where do you stand like this is like the
facts
facts they're they're gonna push their
opinions push their thoughts until
jesus comes back i can make one
i could make one on youtube we're good
we're good
because i
i do think that things would have
been
different
if we were shown the facts like he has
done this for this community has done
this for the country
he's done this with the
countries that we are in agreement with
now
why why don't you want him in office and
a lot a lot of the people that didn't
want him in his office because he
they thought he was a certain way and
they didn't want him and it wasn't it
wasn't based off of things that he did
well then a lot of times it's one small
clip
that goes viral yeah and i'm and i'm i'm
in that record where it was like oh i
don't i don't want him after the fact i
was like
it's kind of worse now isn't it
yeah i don't think a lot of stuff has
happened i'm like joe
mr biden
miss miss harris where you at so yeah
uh
yeah the the the uh
the economy is booming in a way that uh
no one had predicted i
people like uh
paul krugman was saying that when trump
gets in the economy is going to tank no
uh the economy to hit new highs all
right but
but there are so many people among the
intel intelligentsia especially who are
absolutely immune to facts it's just as
if it's as if they took their uh
anti-fat shots uh every every every year
and the facts will just not affect them
so this brings us back
i can understand i mean i really can't
my understanding is limited which is why
i'm going to put this in the form of a
question i can understand the never
trumpers who don't
don't bother me with economic boom
because this man is on my television
screen every single night and i can't
stand him i can understand i can see
that impulse i can i kind of miss him
like honestly they'll say what they want
he was entertaining it was so
entertaining it was interesting he was
funny you can't
he was he was wrong okay a lot of time
he was an [ __ ] but like you remember
when he did that whether like you've
called women pigs and he's like except
like
i don't remember that he he said okay
they said to him
like it was um some fox news reporter
where she's like
okay like donald trump you have said
this about women like you've called
women pigs you've called this this and
this and he said i never said that
except rosie o'donnell
he's he's a very interesting person and
the second consecutive president united
states that i automatically turn off
when i'm watching on television
all right keep the remote right next oh
yeah
okay who was the first obama got it
uh you're totally bipartisan in that
regard
no other way
but the great society the larger point
that you've been making here the great
society the war on poverty
this is now
six
decades of experience yes and we have as
you have said the gap hasn't closed
we've got
dissolution of the family structure
rising crime rates that i don't
understand
how can it be that
the people
now i don't know how to remain
bipartisan but democrats liberals the
progressives
just are not
the evidence is in this has not worked
like after half more than half a century
there's still a refusal to look at the
evidence
yes and then and has even a tendency to
falsify the evidence
and how come
i think people become
attached to a vision
and uh that really warps the way they
see the
human beings have an enormous capacity
to rationalize yeah all right
again notes on the passing scene an
article from the new york times just a
couple of days ago quote now this is a
longish quotation but it's important to
lay out the facts here over the last
decade the charter school movement
gained significant foothold in new york
the movement hoped to set a national
example if charter schools could make it
in a deep blue state like new york they
could make it anywhere
over a hundred thousand students in the
in in the city's charter schools are
doing well on state tests and tens of
thousands are on waiting lists but the
election the election of this november
suggested that the golden era of charter
schools is over
the insurgent democrats democrats did
well across new york but especially in
the state senate have repeatedly
expressed hostility to the movement
close quote and tom saul responds to
that set of facts how
oh
that really is one of the moral outrages
that for many kids
who cut from a very poor background and
who parents may not have had much
education a decent education is the one
thing they have to have
to have a better life
and these schools have been absolutely
uh spectacular
uh the charter schools the charter
schools
the successful ones now there are a few
that that weren't
but uh
for example a few years ago
on the statewide new york statewide math
test
there was an elementary school grade
four i believe
in harlem
which whose students passed those tests
at a higher rate than any fourth grade
kids anywhere in the state of new york
i mean we're talking scarsdale ryancliff
places like that
the success academy schools as a whole
their students
pass
both the math and the english statewide
tests at a higher rate than any school
system
school district
in the entire state of new york
the vast majority of the kids in the
success academy schools are either black
or hispanic
if you look at the five
highest scoring
district school districts in the state
in terms of the percentage of students
who passed the math or the english tests
their average family income
ranges from
four to four times that
of the kids in the success academy
schools to more than nine times
the family income of the kids and the
academy's success academy schools
and yet the mayor of new york is doing
his darndest
to to to put a stop to the expansion of
of schools in general but
his special ira is aimed at the success
academy schools and this is happening
all over the country because they make
the youth the teachers unions look bad
that run the public schools
what what's the political motivation why
would mayor de blasio have it out for
the charter schools such as success
academy well the teachers union are the
major reasons
uh and the we're talking about the the
money they contribute the number of
votes they contribute
uh and
the schools and what and what's
happening again not just in new york but
in other parts of the country including
california
is that the they they have all there's
all kind of chicanery uh to prevent the
charter schools from expanding that's
why you have tens of thousands on the
waiting list it's not that the charter
school is not willing to expand but
every conceivable obstacle is put in
their way
because
everything is connected
they read the votes from the teachers
and the yeah
pearl and you know what's crazy out of
it on a monday you did this to me
at the beginning of the week
you know what's crazy out of the 13 000
per kid
that um this city of chicago gets 50 of
that goes towards like pensions and
teachers wow so it's like not even going
towards it's going towards um i'm pretty
sure 50 is towards pensions so that
means half of the money that each kid
like the school gets for the kid is
going towards teachers that don't even
teach anymore because it's their like um
their their pension
because they weren't expecting people to
live this long because they were
thinking oh let's retire teachers it's
like
that's a good thing
but now the students now get less money
and less funding
and we have to pay
i'm gonna need something after this
goodness
if you let that go at the natural pace
it would be very hard for the public
schools to compete
and one of the things they're doing is
imposing the same kinds of restrictions
on the on on the charter schools that
that made this public school so bad for
example restrictions on being able to
get rid of kids who are
running a muck in
and ruining the education of everybody
else and the charter schools don't
tolerate that
uh the things that are tolerated in the
public schools are unbelievable
uh
so when i asked you a moment ago how do
we bring back the
the standards of the harlem in which you
grew up the answer is that's a hard
thing to do but we do know how to do one
thing we do know how to establish
schools where the kids in present day
harlem have a shot they have a chance of
getting a good idea you don't have to
bring back the past
even if you could
uh uh because we have it in the present
we have to we have this happening and so
we know how to do that and the
democratic establishment in new york
wants to shut it down yes
and the republican establishment stands
mute stands mute
you know i love talking to you but i
really don't know why it's all
it's all discouraging tom you mentioned
again a moment ago the um
the way young americans
flocked to bernie sanders gallup poll
this summer the proportion of americans
age 18 to 29
that holds a favorable view of
capitalism 45 percent the proportion
that holds a favorable view of socialism
51
now i would like you to take a look at a
brief video of alexandria ocasio-cortez
who at the age of 29 calling herself a
democratic socialist has just been
elected to the house of representatives
from new york and although she's not
seated yet in the new congress she went
to washington and one of her first acts
was to participate in a sit-in
in the offices
of house majority leader nancy pelosi
that is to say her the leader of her own
party yes so here's a brief video
i just want to let you all know how
proud i am
of each and every single one of you for
putting yourselves and your body and and
everything on the line to make sure that
we save our planet our generation and
our future and it's so incredibly
important
we have to get to 100 renewable energy
in 10 years there is no other option
tom
to her supporters to the supporters of
bernie sanders to young americans what
would you say
i would say
get some facts first know what you're
talking about before you start spouting
out this kind of stuff
ask one of the things i do in a new new
book as i suggest that uh
there's a certain uh opinion about what
happened in the 1920s where the taxes
were cut from the highest tax rate was
cut down from 73 to 24
and the argument was this is tax cuts
for the rich and i have suggested that
the students and and that uh the
secretary of the treasury did this in in
support of us trickle down theory and so
forth and i suggest that the student
would be a wonderful project to go read
what the secretary of the treasury
actually said andrew mellon in the 1920s
yeah these tax cuts and then uh go on
the internet and get the uh uh internal
revenue official uh data on who paid how
much taxes in the 1920s
and it turns out if you do that you find
that andrew mellon said the exact
opposite of what he has attributed
is attributed to him in textbooks that
have been
uh sold widely for decades on end
through successive
conditions
and what you'll find is that in the
and when the tax rate was at 73 percent
uh the people who are making over uh a
hundred thousand dollars a year and
that's maybe a couple of million in
today's money
paid 30 of the taxes
and after the so-called tax cuts for the
rich
they paid 65 percent of all the taxes
and the people with incomes under 5 000
which is also a nice incoming of the day
uh who were paying uh 15
when the tax rate was
was uh cut
before the tax check was cut and after
it was cut they paid uh just under a
quarter of one percent of all the taxes
and so we hear how and so there's all
kinds of indignation in these scholarly
books we're not talking about just
political propaganda
uh how this this was a bonanza for the
rich and so on and uh people with
ordinary incomes paid practically
nothing in income tax after the tax cuts
and though and millionaires uh the share
of millionaires was uh i think four
percent before that and and it was 19
afterwards
uh and but but the fact that 19 of the
population was millionaires
i understand that right i thought he was
saying
maybe maybe he was oh was he saying 4
was the tax rate i think that was four
percent the tax rate that's what i
thought i was like or 19 like 19
yeah was okay never mind i i simply do
not matter
they they say these words they say isn't
that crazy though that it was published
incorrectly in books
yeah like what
it's like what information are you like
what information are you giving us to
where you're
why are you publishing this incorrectly
do you not know it yourself or you just
don't want to publish the correct
information i want to get elected in the
future
they trickle down and it's like saying
abracadabra
and all the miraculous things follow
from that
tom sol author of a forthcoming edition
of discrimination and disparities would
you close
by reading a brief quotation from your
1987 book one of my favorites a conflict
of visions
logic of course is not the only test of
a theory
empirical evidence is crucial
and yet social visions have shown a
remarkable ability to evade suppress or
explain away discordant evidence
historic evasions of evidence are a
warning not a model
dedication to a cause may legitimately
entail sacrifices of personal interest
but not sacrifices of mind or conscience
dr thomas soul thank you thank you
okay
what are you what'd you think
are you hi how are you holding up
how you
doing it's
like this is a video that i want to show
my family be like what are your thoughts
like you gotta record it when you go
home yeah
i will because i
i have
parents
who essentially were alive or alive
before these laws were implemented and
alive
after these laws were implemented and
it's like how did they how did they
affect you and how
how did they affect what what was life
like before they were implemented and
what was life like after
and
it's
you can't understand no
it's like if you you don't know what you
don't know
and you're just walking around life like
you may know like what you're taught
like the overarching thing like all i
knew about welfare was the simple stuff
but not like the depths of it and how
it just has
affected so much
okay do you think about like you it kind
of makes sense the way the media runs
like you understand that they try to get
people emotional so they don't think
like this yeah and so that's when they
like in the last video when he was
talking about like tribalism versus um
i forgot what the was you know what word
i'm talking about yes whatever i don't
know what the other one was but but it
was because like it was basically saying
like like in the in the case of me it'd
be like a woman like like that's the
excuse instead of personal
responsibility get married do this do
this do this yeah it's like blaming it
on the fact that you're a woman but it's
because they want to get you to vote for
them because they're going to give you
handouts
and those handouts will make you vote
for them
because you want to keep getting them
yeah i'm pretty sure if there was
if there was someone that was going into
office and they're like you know what
we're taking steps to
end
welfare and like people don't understand
what the negative effects it has on
someone they're going to be like no i'm
not voting for them because i i need it
and then and what do they do they'll
paint them as this mean they'll say
and and they're taking away from the the
less fortunate they're taking away from
them they're not going to give them
opportunity they would paint it as it's
negative but it's like
no that'd be something that'd be
helpful
in the long run
and then they go after your because what
they do is like like whenever okay
whenever i bring up these points what do
they do with me they remind me that i'm
a privileged white woman and nothing
that i say can be correct yeah and
that's what they do that's what they do
with these politicians like donald trump
when he was bringing these policies up
they'll say oh he was a rich kid he
failed all these businesses he's like he
he couldn't possibly understand you and
it doesn't matter if the person that's
passing the policy understands you like
and you can tell when someone's like
doing something that's correct like a
lot of times they'll go for their
character yeah and like and when it
shouldn't like to be honest i don't
really care about the person i vote for
as character i care about what policies
do they pass and what are they doing
it's like when i hire someone for a job
it doesn't matter like i don't care what
they do in their free time
true like that's the truth that's their
life
i care about what you do like you on my
channel what are you doing at your dorm
you know i'm kidding like obviously i
want good people but like but like it's
not my business
you can when you come here like if you
watch the video like that's what matters
and that's when i look at like politics
as yeah
and if they make you laugh it's little
perfect they make you chuckle
man
pearl you didn't wreck me on this monday
i'm sorry ah
ideal some meal oh my goodness
okay guys let us know in the comments a
most liked comment we'll react to next i
don't know because you said that last
time we had this one
bruh i know i was like oh for real
i was like you guys gonna do me like
this video please next one make it make
it lighter i'm kidding
um guys and go subscribe to her channel
too new videos are coming soon reaction
videos vlogs behind the scenes they are
coming soon so go subscribe i'm gonna
get her set up you guys will
they're coming i'm telling you they come
i promise pinky promise
yeah go subscribe you wanna do the outro
yeah so if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you
like
and subscribe and then comment down
below what you liked what you disliked
and some videos for us to react to
okay guys bye
[Music]